more than 12 Republicans are at least
paying lip service to the idea that
maybe Donald Trump's national emergency
over the us-mexico border is not really
an emergency but I'm actually not sure
if they really believe it and I'll tell
you about what's going on and then we'll
think about it 12 Republicans 12 plus
Republicans are involved in legislation
that would limit Donald Trump's
emergency powers but it may just be a
political ploy to help Democrats and
I'll explain to you how Senator Mike Lee
of Utah again a Republican as well as
other Republicans say that they want to
stop Trump from quote acting like a king
by taking back the legislative powers
that allow him to do so and this is a
bill that would limit the president's
national emergency power the name of the
bill is absolutely ridiculous it's
called the assuring that robust thorough
and informed congressional leadership is
exercised over national emergencies act
which I guess stands for article one
sort of it's like kind of an
abbreviation but I don't I think some of
the letters are flipped I don't even get
that but the point of what it would do
is require Congress to approve any
national emergency declaration that
lasts more than 30 days if Congress
doesn't approve it the emergency is
automatically terminated when it reaches
30 days and if you believe that he's
being genuine mike lee republican
senator is 100% correct in his
assessment which is that quote emergency
powers are vulnerable to abuse they can
act as a cheat code that undermines our
system of separations of power that is
exactly what Donald Trump is doing with
his immigration related emergency which
is of course not really an emergency no
factual case can be made that there is a
crisis at the us-mexico border and you
have a bunch of other Republican
senators including Utah's Mitt Romney
former governor here in the state of
Massachusetts the Commonwealth of
Massachusetts who are supporting this
what about Mitch McConnell the Senate
Majority Leader often in lockstep with
Trump he says he's quote open to making
some changes
- emergency powers but he's not actually
committing to supporting this law yet so
it all sort of sounds good right
except maybe it's a scam and I'll
explain what I mean if the legislation
passes it wouldn't affect Donald Trump's
emergency declaration for the us-mexico
border it would affect future
declarations so one view is this is
actually genuinely honestly about Trump
and about the possibility that he's
going to do more of this stuff in the
rest of his term but the other view is
that Republicans are worried that
Democrats are going to use emergency
power to their advantage to advance
their agenda and that's really what they
want to prevent by doing this now
because if this truly is a bipartisan
effort you would think that they need to
deal with what's going on right now at
the us-mexico border and maybe they will
in a separate vote via other legislation
but to be an emergency it has to be
demonstrated that action is so
imminently necessary that there is not
even the time possible to involve
Congress with the border Trump had two
years he didn't declare an emergency
until now all of a sudden when Democrats
have taken over control of the House of
Representatives and the border situation
has not gotten worse during those two
years so Trump is obviously using the
emergency powers as a method to try to
bypass congressional oversight the
upside to all of this is even if
Republicans are trying to do this not to
deal with Trump but to deal with
possible future use of emergency powers
by Democrats they must on some level be
worried about losing the White House in
2020 if they believe that this is worth
doing right now and it's sort of the
Wisconsin strategy under Scott Walker
for Republicans when Scott Walker was
the Republican governor in Wisconsin
Republicans and Walker did everything
possible under the law to destroy the
basic institutions of democracy and of
society to take away bargaining power
from teachers in negotiating for better
salary and benefits and then once Scott
Walker became a lame duck they changed
their focus instead tried to change
all sorts of rules to prevent the
incoming Democratic governor from being
able to accomplish anything during their
term and there's a very similar approach
here if you believe that this is not
genuine from Republicans but rather a
way to try to prevent Democrats from
doing the same stuff that Trump is doing
during his presidency to be very clear
there's no guarantee that Donald Trump
loses in November of 2020 and in fact I
think he's likely to win I hate to say
it but I think that that's the most
likely scenario but this could well be
one of those sort of insurance policy
laws that Republicans are trying to pass
to prevent Democrats from doing the same
things using the same mechanisms that
Republicans used to their advantage
that's my question to you do you think
this is genuinely because Republicans
are concerned about Trump's use of
emergency powers do you think it's a
ploy to prevent Democrats from using
emergency powers do you not know do you
think it's both I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show and we've got a good one for
you today one of the day's sponsors is
privacy dot-com slash Pakman which is a
free service that I myself use really
useful in many different ways takes just
a few seconds to link your debit card to
privacy calm then you can create virtual
credit cards that are linked directly to
your bank account and you use those
virtual credit card numbers to buy
things online which protects your actual
debit card so that it's not spread all
over the Internet and one of the best
things about it is how their mobile app
and browser extensions for Chrome and
Firefox make it really easy to use let's
say for example that I'm signing up for
a David Pakman show membership in the
credit card number field I already see
the privacy com icon I just click it
choose which of my virtual credit cards
I want to use and the credit card number
expiration date and security code are
automatically entered I can put in any
zip code I want and I'm done and if you
try to use my credit card number that
you just saw on the screen it doesn't
matter because I've all
deleted that virtual card and that's the
beauty of privacy calm there are a ton
of advantages to using a free service
like this for example you can sign up
for as many free trials as you want then
just delete the virtual credit card you
used and never worry about getting
charged for it it protects you from
getting hacked it protects you when
companies are hacked which happens all
the time it is all completely free all
you have to do is click the link under
this video to get started and for a
limited time they're giving everyone in
our audience $5 towards your first
purchase when you sign up using that
link